finally I have listened to the concerns
of many senior NHS clinicians who say
unpredictable pension tax charges are
making them leave the NHS just when they
are needed the most
the NHS is our biggest employer and we
will shortly publish a long-term
Workforce plan that I promised in the
Autumn statements but ahead of that I
don't want any doctor to retire early
because of the way pension taxes work
it's an issue I've discussed not just
with the current health secretary but a
former Health secretary who kindly took
a break from whatsapping his colleagues
to consider it
as as
Chancellor I have realized the issue
goes wider than doctors no one should be
pushed out of the workforce for tax
reasons so today I will increase the
pension's annual tax-free allowance from
by 50 percent from forty thousand to
sixty thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance
[Music]
tax reform
that will stop over 80 percent of NHS
doctors from receiving a tax charge
incentivize our most experienced and
productive workers to stay in work for
longer and simplify our tax system
taking thousands of people out of the
complexity
audit is because the charge of the
executive is either unpopular or popular
we still have to keep the noise down
because we still have to hear what he
has to say he has more to say
thank you madam Deputy speaker this is a
comprehensive plan to remove the
barriers to work facing those on
benefits those with health conditions
and older workers that is the E of the
employment pillar of today's growth
budget